el fin de semana pasado estuve aquí
mismo en puntacana fui al concierto de
juan luis guerra
y como me pasa entonces lo concierto de
juan luis guerra baile y cante toda la
noche solamente me senté en un momento
cuando tocaron la canción en llegar en
bicicleta
y me sentaré a reflexionar sobre el
estribillo de la canción lo traje porque
quiero compartirlo con ustedes dice no
me diga que los médicos se fueron
no me digan que no tienes anestesia no
me digas que el alcohol se lo bebieron y
que el hilo de coser fue bordado en un
mantel
juan luís guerra escribe esa canción en
el año 1998
es decir hace 20 años
el pudo ver cuál era la realidad de
muchas personas
en república dominicana y le puso música
y el resultado fue una gran bicicleta
y porque yo me senté en ese momento a
reflexionar
porque sencillamente yo no podía
entender y sigo sin entender cómo es
posible que todavía hoy 20 años después
esa sea la realidad de nosotros
y yo quiero hacerle una pregunta pueden
levantar la mano si se animan quiénes de
ustedes creen que hoy por hoy tenemos a
nuestro alcance las herramientas que nos
pueden ayudar a que el niágara en
bicicleta no sea una realidad
yo lo creo
y les voy a hacer otra pregunta no
tenemos que responder la hora
quien ustedes creen que es responsable
de resolver esos problemas
les cuento algo hoy en día los gobiernos
son las instituciones que más decisiones
toman en todo el mundo y en base a la
mayor cantidad de información
la realidad de que las sociedades
grandes pequeñas desarrollados no tienen
como única obligación satisfacer las
necesidades de sus habitantes
gestionando recursos que son escasos eso
es gobernar
y yo estoy segura de que no es una tarea
fácil
nosotros los ciudadanos empoderamos a
los gobiernos para que tomen decisiones
en ese sentido
y esas decisiones impactan nuestras
vidas
desde el momento de nuestro nacimiento
hasta cómo vamos a gestionar nuestra
vejez
entonces si tenemos instituciones como
el gobierno que son los que analizan o
tienen la obligación de analizar la
mayor cantidad de información esas
decisiones impactan y nos impactan a
nosotros yo me acuerdo que hace un
tiempo decidieron poner de una sola vía
una calle un pedazo de una calle en
santo domingo
y esto ocasionó un caos terrible y cada
vez que yo estaba en el tapón yo decía
pero en base a esta información las
autoridades tomaron esta decisión ellos
analizaron cuál era la ruta más
apropiada ellos analizaron el flujo de
los vehículos en las horas regulares y
en las horas pico ellos analizaron cuál
iba a ser el impacto de todos los
movimientos estructurales que tenían que
hacer como consecuencia de esa decisión
yo honestamente no lo sé pero tiendo a
pensar que no
y no nos damos cuenta pero todo desde a
quién y por qué se le adjudica un
contrato público multimillonario hasta
mover la dirección de una vía afecta a
nuestras vidas
en otras palabras aún teniendo las
herramientas para tomar decisiones más
informadas nosotros seguimos tomando
decisiones en excel
yo no sé si han escuchado hablar de la
cuarta revolución industrial quizás no
pero yo estoy segura que todos las
estamos viviendo esto no es más que el
desarrollo y la convergencia de
tecnologías como por ejemplo la
inteligencia artificial como cuando
entras a netflix y te dice creo que esta
película te puede gustar y además
acierta o cuando le dices así en tu
iphone que te haga una llamada o alexa
que te ponga una canción también está el
internet de las cosas las personas que
usan los guaches los relojes
inteligentes o esa cámara que tienes en
tu casa y la puedes ver a través de tu
celular o los drones que graban los
vídeos y toman fotos también está la
computación cuántica la robótica todas
estas tecnologías están impactando
radicalmente la manera en la que vivimos
impactan cómo nos comunicamos como
convivimos como interactuamos están
cambiando lo que hacemos pero también
están cambiando lo que somos
se debe en gran medida a su desarrollo
exponencial
peter diamandis um
futurista emprendedor y propulsor de los
cambios sociales a través del uso de las
tecnologías lo explica de manera súper
sencilla básicamente de la siguiente
manera
aquí hay un gráfico con dos líneas la
línea roja somos nosotros como nos
desarrollamos cómo pensamos cómo
interactuamos de manera lineal si
pensamos en nosotros nuestros padres
nuestros abuelos bisabuelos y más para
atrás vamos a notar que fue muy poco lo
que cambiamos de generación en
generación sin embargo hoy no hoy
vivimos en un mundo que cambia año tras
año y eso se debe al desarrollo
exponencial la línea verde representa
eso
si yo les pido que nos movamos diez
pasos lineales va a ser relativamente
fácil entender a dónde vamos a terminar
pero si yo les pido que nos movamos diez
pasos exponenciales nos habremos movido
aproximadamente medio millón de metros
desde nuestro punto de inicio y eso es
lo que está pasando nosotros pensamos
nuestras instituciones piensan de manera
lineal pero vivimos en un mundo que se
desarrolla de manera exponencial
y estas consecuencias del exponencial
tiene cosas muy positivas para mí una de
las más importantes es que ha
democratizado estas tecnologías y la
manera más fácil de explicar eso es con
los teléfonos inteligentes
se dice que al día de hoy 2018 25 de la
población tiene acceso a teléfonos
inteligentes y se estima que en el 2020
un 85% de la población va a tener acceso
a un teléfono inteligente eso quiere
decir que en dos años habremos duplicado
la cantidad de personas que tienen
acceso a esa tecnología y en términos
reales estamos hablando de casi la
totalidad de la población mundial o sea
un 85%
eso es democratizar
en pocas palabras cada vez más personas
tenemos en nuestro alcance
las herramientas que nos pueden ayudar a
desarrollar esa gran idea que puede ser
la solución por ejemplo a que todas las
personas del mundo tengan acceso a agua
potable oa que nunca más se muera una
madre o un niño dando a luz
sencillamente por razones que son
perfectamente evitables
porque hoy en día
buscar soluciones a esos problemas no
está en las manos de las personas con
poder económico con poder político o
sencillamente con grados altos de
especialización nosotras las mujeres
pocas veces éramos parte de esos
procesos no nos tocaba decidir cómo
cuándo dónde por qué pero eso ya cambio
eso está cambiando y yo siento que soy
un ejemplo de eso yo soy abogada tengo
formación en derecho internacional
privado y si bien he trabajado para la
administración pública y trabajo para
organismo multilateral en materia de
gobierno yo no fui a la universidad a
estudiar tecnología no fui a la
universidad estudia ciencias ni
administración pública yo me uní a este
proceso de manera intuitiva
sencillamente buscando soluciones
diferentes
y lo mejor de todo es que nadie tuvo que
darme el permiso nadie tuvo que
permitirme lo unirme a una idea que yo
entiendo tiene el potencial de dejarle
un mundo mejor a mis hijos fue mi
decisión
esa idea tiene como misión hacer que
nuestros gobiernos sean más eficientes
más efectivos y más adaptados a la era
del exponencial
nosotros reconocemos que los gobiernos
han hecho muchos esfuerzos en adaptarse
a la era digital y en adaptarse a la era
del exponencial sin embargo nosotros
creemos que pueden y que deben hacer más
porque hay una relación directa entre un
sector público altamente eficiente y un
desarrollo social tangible
pero no tenemos que esperar que sean los
gobiernos los que hagan todo el trabajo
y por eso nosotros pensamos que es el
mejor momento para ayudar a los
gobiernos a hacer algo que solamente
ellos pueden hacer y eso es decidir cómo
vamos a gestionar los fondos públicos
para eso nosotros estamos creando
un ecosistema de software para gobiernos
con base en la inteligencia artificial
que nos va a ayudar a digitalizar
optimizar y escalar todos los procesos y
las tomas de decisiones la idea es
simplificar cada una de las operaciones
gubernamentales un producto a la vez
productos diseñados y pensados para los
gobiernos que tenemos hoy y en base
estrictamente a sus necesidades quiénes
estamos detrás de este sueño somos
personas comunes
sencillamente nos une la idea de que con
la tecnología que tenemos hoy y con el
conocimiento que tenemos hoy podemos
hacer que nuestros gobiernos sean más
eficientes más efectivos y más adaptados
a la era del exponencial porque los
gobiernos bueno los gobiernos primero
son las empresas más grandes del mundo
segundo son los tomadores de decisiones
más grandes del mundo y sencillamente si
los gobiernos hay cambios hay resultados
que no pueden ser sostenibles en el
tiempo
entonces
buscando solución a estos problemas no
hemos encontrado evidentemente con que
no es un problema fácil y sabemos que se
han hecho muchísimos esfuerzos y se
siguen haciendo muchos esfuerzos desde
distintos enfoques para solucionar o
para hacer que los gobiernos operen de
manera distinta nuestro enfoque es
simplificar el problema y buscar una
solución tecnológica que pueda ayudar a
ese problema
el primer reto o el primer enfoque que
tenemos son las compras públicas porque
porque sencillamente los gobiernos son
hoy por hoy una de las entidades que más
consumen bienes y servicios entonces
como operacional izamos y cómo hacemos
más efectivo los procesos de compra
gubernamentales que al final se hacen
con mi dinero y con su dinero
ese es nuestro reto y la apuesta es una
plataforma o un mercado digital de
compras públicas menores imaginémonos
algo así como un amazon para gobiernos
en resumen nosotros queremos ayudar a
los gobiernos a que tengan las
herramientas que puedan hacerlos tener
un mejor desempeño y con eso queremos
impactar de manera positiva la vida de
las personas que viven en un determinado
país
ahora
como marcamos nosotras las mujeres la
diferencia dentro de esa revolución
dentro de este proceso dentro de esta
exponencial ida
ahorita hablábamos de lo crítico que es
tomar decisiones y de lo difícil que es
tomar decisiones pero más importante que
eso yo creo que es tener conciencia del
poder que tienen nuestras decisiones
porque si nosotras como mujeres queremos
marcar la diferencia yo creo que hay que
empezar por darse el permiso de tomar
decisiones de manera más intuitiva más
femenina y más natural y sobre todo sin
miedo a que por hacerlo de esa manera se
nos perciba como personas sensibles y
muchas veces hasta incapaces
y porque yo digo esto porque yo me he
dado cuenta que cuando yo quiero tomar
decisiones pero además quiero encajar en
los parámetros establecidos o sea el
mundo de los hombres me pierdo de
muchísimas cosas y de lo más importante
que me pierdo es de ser natural pero
además de eso me pierdo de ser flexible
me pierdo de conectar con los demás me
pierdo de ser empática
y nosotras las mujeres tenemos una
condición muy muy especial y es que se
nos hace muy fácil tomar excelentes
decisiones desde el diálogo desde la
colaboración desde la sensibilidad y eso
más que debilidad yo creo que es una
gran fortaleza que tenemos que rescatar
y que tenemos que potenciar
es sumamente importante que nosotros
entendamos que el poder de nuestra
decisión tiene el mismo valor que el
poder de cualquier otro ser humano
sencillamente porque yo también tengo la
capacidad de lograr el cambio y sí
mi decisión es transforman mis
decisiones tienen poder
entonces la invitación es a tomar
conciencia de la revolución en la que
estamos viviendo
y de lo ilimitado de sus posibilidades
vamos a empezar a pensar de manera
exponencial vamos a inspirarnos a
inspirar a otros en la posibilidad de
que es real crear el cambio y vamos a
tomar decisiones sobre todo queriendo
que esas decisiones tengan un impacto
que sea sostenible y que beneficia a la
colectividad las mujeres que vinieron
antes que nosotros nos abrieron el
camino ya nosotras somos líderes ya
nosotros somos parte activas del cambio
y la mejor manera de nosotras no
permitir que todo ese esfuerzo haya sido
en vano es actuando
nuestro poder de traer a la mesa nuestra
sensibilidad nuestra visión única del
mundo va a ser mayor en la medida en la
que nos reconozcamos como mujeres porque
eso en sí mismo es un sello distintivo
nosotras somos singulares y tenemos que
ejercer esa singularidad
yo espero que a partir de ahora tengamos
una idea mucho más clara de quién es
responsable de contribuir con el cambio
muchas gracias